right let's go to the domestic front now
and the political situation in Scotland
yesterday the first Minister Hamza Yusuf
had to stop a speech following a very
loud intervention from a Heckler at a
special conference meant to set out how
the s p would plot a path to
Independence well heckling is probably
the least of his worries with the party
still mired in chaos following Financial
scandals and arrests including that of
his predecessor Nicholas sturgeon oh and
the polls are looking pretty Grim for
the party that has dominated Scottish
politics for so long well I'm joined now
by the first Minister Hamza Yusuf
good morning Mr Yusuf
joining us and just as per your
introduction it's probably worth me
saying that in virtually every single
poll that has come out of course we
still continue to be the party at least
every single other party in Scotland but
I just thought I'd just uh thought that
India given your a very kind
introduction of me well kind of you to
fill us in on that but let's we'll come
back to that in a second
um you said yesterday that you would
make the next general election a
referendum on Independence does that
mean that as your predecessor it's not
what I said that if you've got 50 of the
vote you would consider that a mandate
for Independence but would it also mean
that if you didn't get 50 you just drop
it
first of all it's not what I said so
I'll clarify in a second it's worth
reminding people that of course are
preferred option the option for which we
have multiple mandates for the option in
which the majority of the Scottish
Parliament backs is of course without
legally binding referendum and that has
been denied Time and Time Again by the
UK government so my message is pretty
simple we will use the next general
election to test the proposition we'll
put a very simple proposition to the
people of Scotland on page one line one
of our Manifesto a vote for the SNP is a
vote for Scotland to become an
independent country and if we win that
general election we'll then seek to
negotiate with the UK government how we
give Democratic effect to that
proposition and we're only going down
this route of course because I continue
to reiterate because the UK government
Westminster parties continue to deny us
the right to our reference but forgive
me it's an interrupting when you say if
we win that general election what does
that constitute does that mean most
teach in Scotland does that mean fifty
percent of the vote what does winning
the general election sure I'm happy I'm
I'm happy to clarify but I suspect you
have covered more general elections than
I have even been involved in campaigning
and every single general election
everybody knows the rules of a general
election the party that wins the most
seats wins the general election so again
if you want to test that proposition for
popular support which is a fair enough
ask to do in fact it's what we want to
do if you want to test a proposition for
popular support you do that via
referendum that's no different to any
Democratic country in the world that
wants to test a proposition for popular
support but the rules of a general
election are thus that of course the the
party that wins the most seats wins that
general election
okay so if you win if you win more seats
than anybody else you are going to take
that as a mandate to push for a further
uh referendum now both Rishi sumac and
Kia stalma have said it doesn't really
matter what comes out you're not getting
one what are you going to do to force
their hands
and by the way well first and foremost
it's legal for them to say that
but first and foremost I would put it to
Kirsty sunak very simply you continue to
tell Scotland that this is a voluntary
Union then prove it if you're saying
that you can't have your Independence
via referendum I'm afraid we're more
accept any uh Mandy that's given to you
via a general election this is a
voluntary Union how on Earth does
Scotland become independent but the
question you ask is a very fair one and
the second part of my speech in fact one
of the main uh main arguments I was
making to our activists and reminding
our activists base of is that it's so
important for us to ensure that we have
a consistent majority supporting
Independence so while of course we'll be
campaigning in that general election
what we're doing right now is
campaigning to make sure that we have
that settled well that consistent
majority in Scotland that support
Independence because it is the power of
the people that I don't doubt will break
westminster's in transitions oh
and just
something here I mean we're talking
about democracy
um
there's a general election and either Mr
sunak or starma are in Downing Street
they will have gone to the country with
a Manifesto that says we are not going
to have another referendum they will
have one
in what way is it not Democratic for
them to fulfill their mandate given to
them by a ref a general election of the
United Kingdom Scotland's not
independent yet well there's two two
well there's two points to make on that
of course if we beat labor in Scotland
then of course we win the general
election here in Scotland if you are
saying that Scotland can continue to be
denied a referendum because they are out
voted by the fact that the rest of the
UK have more seats than I would say to
you very gently that that is the
Democratic deficit which we are
continuing to rail against I'm afraid
because there is a deficit in that
regard so you are you are essentially
saying unless the rest of the UK allows
you to become independent allows you to
have a referendum and that's the only
way you can become independent that to
me doesn't sound like a voluntary Union
at all
okay all right well we could go on about
that but let's let's go on to
um the circumstances uh in which you
govern
um perhaps the best way of persuading
everybody that Scotland should be
independent would be to have
um a brilliant performance by the SNP
government in Scotland so let's address
a couple of issues which don't depend on
westminster's say so for agreement for
example the NHS you were responsible for
it in Scotland between May 21st uh May
21 and March 1923. now the number of
patients on waiting list in Scotland
is up to 780 000 there are over 18 000
people died waiting for treatment a rise
of 39 compared with 2019.
um it's not a stellar record is it
you're suggestion that somehow that is
unique to Scotland I'm not suggesting
it's Unique I'm just saying it's very
good for Scotland well it's the it's the
it's the proposition it's the
proposition uh that is the premise that
underlines your question that would be
absurd of course because a global
pandemic by its definition has affected
Health Services right across the world
the pandemic was the biggest shock that
hit our NHS and it's almost
75-year existence in terms of the NHS
here in Scotland we stand in a record
that shows that Scotland's a e
departments are the best performing for
well over seven years in fact in the
winter that's just passed there was only
one nation in the UK that didn't lose a
single day to strikes in the NHS that
was Scotland of course while I was a
health secretary and when it comes to
those longest weights on the NHS if you
look at those people who've been waiting
for over two years we've made dramatic
reductions when it's inpatients
outpatients or indeed for those that are
waiting for a diagnostic test so there
are there are challenges with the NHS
and longer to pretend otherwise but
that's undoubtedly being exacerbated by
that Global pandemic but absolutely
focused on making sure that we can
recover our NHS and social care and just
on that point you say it's not connected
uh to anything that Westminster does but
we all know that you don't recover your
NHS without recovering your social care
one of the biggest challenges we have of
course has been brexit if you ask
anybody involved in Social care they
will tell you how much of the workforce
and social care will be lost
but Scotland didn't vote for we're
wandering a bit away from your
government's performance it's still not
better
if you want to talk to if you wanted to
talk about the S P's record of course
just to report out two weeks ago showing
that because of our actions an estimated
90 000 children will be lifted out of
poverty if you want to look at our
record and Ernst young report out just
last week shows that Scotland outpaces
the rest of the UK and Europe when it
comes to foreign direct investment you
want to talk about our record you've got
the best performing at any departments
in the entire UK if you want to talk
about our record you have more young
people going to University from deprived
areas in Scotland than ever before I can
go on and on and on if you want but
ultimately it is the people that's not
and they keep trusting they would say
that you're responsible for some of the
uh let's call them shenanigans that have
taken place in the party but you have
inherited uh a situation which has
damaged the SNP can I just get clear one
thing um
are there any circumstances in which you
would remove the whip from the MSP and
former first Minister Nicholas sturgeon
I'm not going to get hypotheticals about
what might happen in a live police
investigation you should know better
than that of course that is is
inappropriate for ministers first
ministers any elected politician to of
course comment on what is a live police
investigation I'm just asking if you
could imagine I've made it I'm not
asking you what look I've made it very
very obviously if you can imagine
circumstances in which she would lose
the whip
again I'm not going to meet this about
either Nicholas Sturgeon or anybody else
but whatever else is those that have
been released without charge have been
consistent they have not had the whip
removed for them or their party
membership suspended it will keep that
situation under review but as a live
police investigation and one that I'm
not keen to comment on for that very
reason
you do accept though don't you that this
has been pretty catastrophic for your
party the chief executive of the party
arrested in April
um missing 30 000 members a perfect
purchase of a luxury motor home worth
000 pounds um
did you know any of that when you stood
for the leadership
no and I made that clear at the time and
look I'm not going to argue with your
central proposition I mean it's probably
been the most difficult few months of
the party's recent modern history but
I'm the leader and I've got to make sure
I do everything I can to ensure that
there's stability within the party that
we are open and transparent that's why
instructed a governance and financial
oversight uh financial review as well as
the parties conducting that at the
moment but it's also why it's important
for me to Galvanize our party and that's
why we had such a great convention here
in the city of Dundee just yesterday so
despite all those challenges it's worth
me reiterating what I did at the very
opening of the interview we are still
the most popular party in Scotland of
virtually every single poll and of
course we have by far the most members
than any other political party here in
Scotland so that's a pretty good base to
build upon
I I just want to give you the
opportunity to respond to what I think
some people say you've been a very
senior member of the SNP government for
a long time best part of a decade
it is hard to understand that you would
not have any consciousness of any of
these issues until after you became
elected as the party's leader
you can understand why that seems
bizarre to an outsider
not really because nobody's really asked
that question before because people
generally tend to understand that you
can be a senior member of the government
that doesn't mean you're a senior member
necessarily of the party because I've
actually never had an office building a
position uh in the party and for all
almost 20 years I've been involved in
the party I've had a number of pretty
tricky jobs that have kept me busy in
government whether it was transport
Minister Justice secretary or indeed
Health secretary as you just alluded to
a moment ago so uh you know I'll be up
front you ask me a pretty straight
question that I know about the various
different issues that you raised before
they were made public in the media no
the answer to that very simply as well
all right one other thing which has
caused you quite a lot of uh trouble
um I know that the parliament has passed
the gender recognition Reform Bill but
it is an extremely unpopular Bill
according to polls in Scotland are
barely one in five people supported
labor has said it won't support it
Tories have said they weren't supported
are you going to continue pushing for
that through uh legal action in the
courts
well first of all let me correct your
assertion again and this is really basic
actually that of course the labor party
did support the gender reform
recognition but that's the liberal
Democrats as did the greens uh as of the
s p and indeed some members of the
conservative parties who had members of
every single party uh supporting the
gender record for uh recognition reform
uh Bill actually this is a pretty simple
issue of democracy whether you agree
with the substance of the grr bill or
not we have a bill that's been passed by
the majority of Parliament that is
within our art of all competency which
has then been vetoed by a UK government
that to me is another example of a
Westminster government that's looking
and seeking to undermine Devolution time
and time again all right forgive me I'm
just interrupting you because uh
something has just landed which I just
want to ask you about
um it's the breaking news Scotland fire
and rescue is saying that alongside
other services across the UK the
national 999 system is experiencing
technical problems and they're urging
people to phone other numbers
um your reaction how worrying is that as
somebody who's been responsible for
one of those emergency services and
health and so on
that is of course concerning him we're
of course working with Scottish fire and
rescue and others to see if that
situation can be resolved as you know
the UK Works uh right across the UK on
that 999 Airwaves system so any problems
we're of course work and collaborate
with Partners right across the UK in
that regard but uh of course the the
situation as you've expressed it is one
of concern
first Minister thank you very much for
your time this morning it's been good to
talk to you thank you